man meet the creeper totally [ __ ] the
girl on the train the girl on the train
is a psychological thriller slash murder
mystery starring Emily Blunt Emily Blunt
rides this train every day she goes by
these houses she sees the people in the
houses she makes up stories about them
she starts feeling like she has a
connection with him and then one day one
of them goes missing so now is a murder
mystery who did it alright let's talk
about what I liked about in his movie
Emily Blunt Emily Blunt straight-up
brings it in this one going for an Oscar
and she does a damn good job she does a
good job at showing someone who is
straight-up mentally in pain but showing
the vulnerability to it is one of the
things I liked about the movie is it
puts it into perspective you see people
in your life or world maybe you're just
crossing paths maybe you work with them
maybe you're dating them and they're
kind of nuts but this movie does bring
it into focus where it's like something
happened it downward spiral happened in
their lives is to bring them to this
point that's what you feel with Emily
Blunt more or less you do pity er
however it does show the actions and
reactions that have happened leading up
to this point er live you're like you're
not the most likeable person the movies
kind of building you up to be a [ __ ]
human being I'm not above a movie
building tension you have to build
tension in a movie like there's a
psychological murder mystery without
tension you there would be none of but
my god this was the long haul the movie
just do a good job at putting you in the
perspective of someone who does have
issues she the girls got baggage so but
she's trying to piece things together
you're trying to piece things together
but because she doesn't have all the
pieces you definitely don't have all the
pieces and maybe her perspectives a
little stewed you just don't know what's
going on the movie does a good job at
making you as confused as she is the
movie also does a good job of just
confusing you period like with the
transitions the transitions in this
movie were wonky because it jumps around
we're talking Pulp Fiction style and
that doesn't bother me
usually when the movie does a bad job at
transitioning from the past into the
present not actually having it clear
that it just did that it'll say like two
months ago or four months ago whatever
the time-leap is but then when it comes
back to the present when the flashback
is over you're like are we in the
present I'm still in the past you do get
it figured out you get it ironed out in
your head but it takes a minute and when
it takes a minute
do that often enough in the movie those
minutes stack up to really compromise
the experience as a whole guys in the
end the girl on the trend was one of
those interesting premise but boring
movies with good acting but some wonky
execution that really did compromise it
as a whole when it feels this boring in
this choppy for this much of it really
does just drag it down in the mud
there's gonna be a short review because
the movie's heavily relies on continuing
revelation carrying the movie and if I
explain too much then it's gone so I'll
just say the girl on the train would
probably be a better time if you're
drunk yeah and now it's a party wait it
was choppy when I was sober drunk I'm
not understand a thing I'll explain it
like this if you've heard nothing else
in this video if the hands are too
distracting for you please hear this so
you put my hands down here you go this
is a movie you'll need to watch twice
but you'll only want to watch once so
hence the conundrum alright guys so girl
on a train have you seen it what did you
think about it was your favorite
psychological thriller of all time
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]